You've probably seen this paper around town,
you're thinking, oh, is that 1910?
No, this is 1978 and Texas Presidents
don't look that different today.
You may know that the 13th Amendment abolished slavery
except as a punishment for a crime,
but did you know that every Texas prison established
before the 1980s is built on a former slave plantation?
The 60s, 70s, this is last week.
If you drive down to Southeast Texas today,
you may see a group of mostly black and brown men
working in a field for no pay.
You are not allowed to go around the uniform forever.
Okay, I'll head back that way or what's the best way out.
All right, we'll wait until you're allowed to either.
I can go out.
You can get shot for driving around the unit.
We've got guns and all these carriages
that just break the town.
So this is where you will remain a girl.
Texas is one of a handful of states,
all of them in the South,
that don't pay any wages to prisoners.
If a Texas prisoner refuses to participate in farm labor,
they can be punished with 30 days
and isolation in the South.
And that is what happened to Robert Hockley.
I'm like, it's a way in hell, I'm being kind.
This is him standing outside Clemens prison,
which is a prison he went to when he was 17 years old.
From 1996 to 2000, he picked cotton by hand.
That was on the same land
that slaves were working in the 1800s.
He says it's not a rhyme to slavery,
it's not something like slavery.
In 1996, I was a slave.
The number one complaint the prisoners have about the condition
is the heat.
Most Texas prisons lack AC and housing areas.
I don't know how to describe except it's miserable.
These are Texas prisons that have some AC and housing areas.
These are Texas prisons that have no AC and housing areas.
Adopt that's orange means a prison
that was built on a former slave plantation.
I was my introduction into burning hell.